alright hey everyone welcome back so
what we'll see today is additional
elaborations on the e/m on the
expectation-maximization
harbor volley and so what you see today
is go over you know quick recap of all
we talked about
eeehm on Monday and then describe how
you can monitor if eeehm is converging
and on Monday we talked about the
mixture of gaussians model and started
deriving Ian's for that I won't just
take these two equations and map it back
to specifically the E&M steps that you
saw for the mixture of gaussians models
to see exactly how these map - you know
updating the weights of UI and so on how
you should derive the m-step and then
most of what I went spend today talking
about is the model called the factor
analysis model and this is model useful
but for data there can be very
high-dimensional even when you have very
few training examples so what I want to
do is talk a bit about properties of
Gaussian distributions and then describe
the factor analysis model some more
about Gaussian distributions and then
we'll derive e/m for the factor analysis
model and once talked about factor
analysis with two reasons I guess one is
you know useful algorithm in an episome
right and second the derivation for
ian's for factor analysis is actually
one of the trickier ones and there are
key steps and how you actually derived
in E and M steps that I think you learn
better or you better master better by
going through the factor analysis
example ok um so just a recap last
Monday or on Monday we had talked about
the Ian algorithm and we wound up
figuring out this estep and this n step
remember that if this is the log
likelihood that you trying to maximize
what the estep does is it constructs a
lower bound then this is a funk
theta so this thing on the right hand
side this is a function of the
parameters theta what we proved last
time was that that function is a lower
bound of the log-likelihood right and
depending on what you choose for Q you
get different lower bound so one choice
of Q you make it this little bow for a
different choice Q might get that lower
bound for a different choice you may get
that low about and what the e set does
is it uses Q together lower bound this
tight that just touches the lock like
here at the current value of theta and
what the M set does is it chooses the
parameters later that maximizes that all
right so those are eeehm algorithm that
we saw now um I want to step through how
you would take this you know slightly
abstract mathematical definition of VM
and derive a concrete algorithm that you
would implement right and in you know in
Python and so let's let's just step
through this for the mixture of
gaussians model so for the mixture of
gaussians model we had a model for P of
X I comma Z I which given CI times P I
and a model was that Z is a multinomial
with some set of parameters Phi oh and
so you know the probability of Z I J is
equal to Phi J right so Phi is just a
vector of numbers that sum to one
specifying what's the chance of Z being
each of the K possible to speak values
and then we have that X i given the CI
equals J that that is Gaussian with some
mean and what we said last time was that
um this is a lot like the Gaussian
destroying an Alice model and the the
trivial one trivial difference is this a
sigma j instead of Sigma right GTA call
centers analysis had the same Sigma
every cost but that's not the key
difference the key difference is that
in this density estimation problem Z is
not observable z is a latent random
variable Raven which is why we have all
this machinery of so now that you have
this model let's see so now that you
have this model this is how you would
derive the E and the M steps right so
the e step is you know you have Q I of
CI right but let me just write this as
qi of Zi equals J this is sort of the
probability of Z I equals J I know this
notation a little bit strange but under
the Qi distribution what do you want the
chance of Z being equal to J right and
so in the estep you were said that to P
of Z I equals J given X I parameterize
by all of the parameters and we actually
saw with Bayes rule right how you would
fetch this out okay and what we do in
the Estep is saw this number right in
what we wrote as W IJ last time okay and
so you remember if you a mixture of two
gaussians maybe that's the first girls
in the second gaussian you have an
example X I here or so looks like it's
more likely I come from the first and
second girls yet and so this would be
reflected in W IJ that that example is
assigned more to the first gaussian then
to second gaussian so what you implement
encodes is you know you write code to
compute this number and store it in W IJ
and then for the m-step
you will want to maximize over the
parameters of the model right fine mu
and signal these are the parameter
parameters of the mixture of gaussians
of some of the why some of the Zi and so
the way you actually derived this is
your write this as sum of I so Zi you
know takes on the certain to speak to
the value so Zi to turn turn Zi into J
right so Zi can be I guess one or two of
you have make sure to gaussians you sum
of all the indices of the different
clusters W IJ times log of the numerator
is going to be
times pi J that's the numerator and so
you know this term is equal to this
first gaussian term times that second
term right because this term is P of X i
given Z I write the parameters and this
is just Q and then if you take this and
divide it by W IJ okay
so I'm gonna step you through the steps
you would go through if you're deriving
um using that you know you step in M
said we wrote up above but if you're
deriving this for the mixture of
gaussians modeled and these are the
steps of algebra so in order to perform
this maximization what you will do is
you want to maximize this formula right
this big double summation with respect
to each the parameters Phi mu and Sigma
and so what you would do is you know
take this big formula right and take the
derivatives with respect to each of the
parameters so you take the derivative
respective mu J yeah thought that out is
that big formula on the left set it to
zero right and take and then and then it
turns out if you do this you will derive
that nu J should be equal to some K and
this is what we said is how you update
the means mu right the WI J's are the
strength with which X I so W IJ is
informally this is the strength
with which Xie is a sign right -
Gaussian and more formally this is
really P of Z I equals J given X I the
parameters and so so you end up with
this formula but the way you compute
this formula is by the the rigorous way
to show this is the right formula
updating you J is looking at this
objective taking derivative saying there
is equal zero to maximize and therefore
deriving that equation for new J you
know by by solving for the value of MU J
that maximizes this expression and
similarly you know you take derivatives
respective this thing respective fires
said it's a zero take derivatives of
this thing and set that to zero and
that's how you would derive the update
equations in the m-step for fire and for
sigma as well okay um so and and so for
example when you do this you find that
the optimal value for Phi is we had this
near the start of Monday's lecture as
well okay um so this is the process of
how you would look the estep CM steps I
wrote up and apply it to a specific
model such as the mixtures of gaussians
model and that's how you you know solve
for the maximization in DM step okay and
so what I'd like to do today is describe
the application of VM to a more complex
model called the factor of analysis
model and so it's important that so I
hope you understand the mechanics of how
you do this because we're gonna do this
today for a different model
questions about this with why move on oh
so in order to you know foreshadow a
little bit what we'll see when it comes
down to the mixture of gaussians model
excuse me the factor analysis model
which we talked about which is what was
famous today talking about in the factor
analysis model instead of Zi being
discrete Zi will be continuous right and
the paper zi will be distributed
Gaussian so in the mixture of gaussians
model we had a joint distribution for X
and Z where X was a discrete random
variable so in the factor analysis model
will describe a different model you know
for p.m. X and Z where Z is continuous
and so instead of sum over Zi just be an
integral over Zi of d zi right so
instead of sum becomes integral and and
it turns out that yeah well right yeah
and it turns out that if you go through
the derivation of the EEM algorithm that
we worked out on Monday all of the steps
with Jenson equality all of those steps
work exactly that's before many of you
check every single step for whether Zi
was continuous it work the same as
before if you have changed the sum to an
integral all right
so so I want to mention one other view
of yam that's equivalent everything
we've seen up until now which is um let
me define J of theta comma Q okay says
that phone that you've seen a few times
now what we proved on Monday was um Ella
theta is greater than or equal to J of
theta comma Q right and this is true for
any theta and any choice of Q okay so
using using Jensen's inequality you can
show that you know J for any choice of
theta and Q is a lower bound for the
log-likelihood of theta so it turns out
that an equivalent view of PM as
everything was seen before is that in
the Estep what you're doing is maximize
J with respect to Q and in the m-step
maximize J with respect to theta right
so in the East step you're picking the
choice of Q that maximizes this and it
turns out that the choice of Q we have
will set J equal to L and then M step
maximizes this respect to theta and
pushes the value of L
even higher so this algorithm is
sometimes called coordinate ascent if
you have a function of two variables and
you are twice respected this also has
respect to this they go back and forth
and optimize the respective one at a
time that's a procedure that sometimes
called coordinate ascent because you're
maximizing respect to one coordinate at
a time and so e/m is a coordinate ascent
algorithm relative to this cost function
J right and and and you know and on
every iteration J ends up being sent to
L which is why you know that as the
algorithm increases J you know that the
log likelihood is increasing on every
iteration and if you want to track
whether the e/m algorithm is converging
or how was converging you can plot you
know the value of J or the value of L on
successive iterations and see this very
valid data is going are monotonically
and then when it plateaus and isn't
improving anymore then you might have a
sense that the algorithm is converging
all right
okay so that's it the basic algorithm
and make sure of gaussians what I want
to do now is and it's going to talk
about the factor analysis out all right
so um you know that the factor analysis
algorithm will work actually so over the
compare and contrast mixture of
gaussians with factor analysis are
talking about a little bit which is uh
for the mixture of gaussians let's say N
equals 2 and M equals 100 right see if a
dataset with two features x1 and x2 so
any two or two and maybe of a data set
that looks like this
you know then make sure to gaussians we
were a pretty good model for this data
set right now say one gaussian there for
the second gaussian there you can kind
of capture a distribution like this with
a mixture of two gaussians and this is
one illustration of when when you apply
make sure gaussians in this picture M is
much bigger than n right you have a lot
more examples then you have dimensions
where I will not use mixture of
gaussians and where you see the minute
factor analysis will apply maybe if M is
about similar to N no even n is or even
M it's much less than okay and so um
just for purposes of illustration let's
say M equals 30 and equals 100 right so
let's say you have a hundred dimensional
data but only thirty examples and so to
make this more concrete you know many
years ago there was a Stanford PhD
student that was placing temperature
sensors are around different standard
buildings and so what you do is model
you measure the temperature at many
different places right around campus but
if you have a hundred sensors you know
taking a hundred temperature readings
around campus but only thirty days of
data or maybe thirty examples then you
would have a hundred dimensional data
because each example is a vector of a
hundred temperature readings you know at
different points around this building
say but you may have only thirty
examples of if you say thirty thirty
such vectors and so the application that
the Stanford PhD student at the time was
working on was he wants a model P of X
right so this is X as a vector of a
hundred sends a hundred temperature
readings because if something goes wrong
for example it has a bad case if there's
a fire in one of the rooms then there'll
be a very anomalous temperature reading
in one place and if you can model P of X
and if you ever observe a value of P of
X that is very small you would say oh
looks like there's an anomaly there
right and we ratio let's worry about
fires on Stanford the use cases
was it an energy conservation if someone
unexpectedly these a window open in the
building you were studying you know and
it was hot and was it and it's it's
winter and it's warmer inside the
building and ku air blows in and the
temperature of one Broome Johnson and
all this way you want to realize that
something was going wrong with the
windows or the or the temperature in
part of the building okay so for the
application like that you need to model
P of X as a Joint Distribution over you
know all of the different senses right
actually
if you imagine maybe just in this room
let's say we have thirty senses in this
room then the temperatures that the
thirty different points in this room
will be highly correlated with each
other but how do you model this vector
of a hundred hundred original vector
with relatively small training set so it
turns out that the problem with applying
a Gaussian model right so one thing
could do is model this as a single
Gaussian and say that X is distributed
right and if you look at your training
sets of thirty examples and find the
maximum likely estimate parameters you
find that the maximum likelihood
estimate of MU is just the average and
the best of like the estimate of Sigma
is this but it turns out that if M is
less than equal to n then Sigma this
covariance matrix will be singular and
singular I just means our non-invertible
I'll step for an illustration in a
second
but if it looks like formula for the
Gaussian density right so the Gaussian
density kind of looks like this right
abstracting away some details and when
the covariance matrix is singular then
this term this determinant term will be
zero so you end up with 1 over 0 and
then Sigma inverse is also undefined or
blows up to infinity or depending how
you think about it right so you know the
inverse of a matrix like um 110 right
would be I guess 1 1 over 10 and an
example of a non invertible matrix so
singular matrix would be this and you
can't actually calculate the inverse of
that matrix right so it turns out that
um if your number of training examples
is less than the dimension of the data
if you use the usual formula to derive
the maximum likelihood estimate of Sigma
you end up with a covariance matrix that
a singular singular just means
non-invertible which means the
covariance ratios would look like this
and so you know the Gaussian density we
try to compute P of X you get you can't
get infinity over 0
oh sorry not actually zero over zero
doesn't matter it's all bad um and I
think let me just illustrate what this
looks like
which is um let's say M equals 2 and N
equals 2 right so you have two
dimensional data x1 and x2 and so N
equals two and the number of training
examples 0 2 so it turns out that let's
see
so you see me draw contours of Gaussian
densities like this right like the lips
is like that it turns out that if you
have two examples the two dimensional
space and you compute the most likely
maximum likelihood estimate the
parameters of the Gaussian if it is a
there then it turns out that these
contours will look like that except that
instead of being very thin as I'm
drawing it it'll be it'll be infinitely
skinny see and ever be Gaussian density
where I can't draw lines you know of
zero width on the whiteboard right but
it turns out that the contours will be
squished infinitely thin so you end up
with a Gaussian density all of whose
mass is on the straight line over there
with infinitely thin cons was just you
know this is question centers on the on
the plane I guess or on the line
connecting these two points and so this
is so first there are practical
numerical problems right as in your
network so zero over zero if you try to
compute P of X for any example and
second this is this very poorly
conditioned Gaussian density puts all
the Prairie mouths on this line segments
and so any example right over there just
a little bit off has no probably mas
because has probably loss of zero a
probably density of 0 because the
Gaussian is squish infinitely thin you
know on that on that line okay but but
you know this just not be good just this
is just not a good model right for this
danger
so what we're gonna do is uh come up
with a model that will work even for for
these applications even even for a
dataset like this right
there's actually a I think the the
origins of the factor analysis model one
of the very early applications was
actually a psychological testing where
if you have a you know administer a
psychology exam two people to measure
different personality attributes right
so you might measure you might have a
hundred questions or measure a hundred
psychological attributes but have a data
set of thirty persons right okay you
know doing doing psych research
collecting you know running survey data
is harder it's a myriad of a sample of
30 people and each person answers a
hundred quiz questions and so each
person is one gives you one example X
and the dimension of this is hundred
image now B of only thirty of these and
so if you want to model P of X try to
model how correlated are the different
psychological attributes of people rate
um Louis intelligence correlated math
ability is that correlated with language
ability is that correlated with other
things then how do you build a model for
P of X okay alright so um if the
standard Gaussian model doesn't work
let's look at some alternatives one
thing you could do is constrained Sigma
to be diagonal right so Sigma is a
covariance matrix is an N by n
covariance matrix so in this case be one
hundred one hundred matrix but let's say
we constrain it to just have diagonal
entries and zeros on the off diagonals
right so these giant zeroes I mean the
diagonal entries of the square matrix
are these values and all of the entries
of the diagonals you're set to zero so
that's one thing you could do and this
turns out to be this turns out to
correspond to constraining your Gaussian
to have axis aligned contours so this is
a Gaussian with zero diagonals this
would be another one this would be
another one so these are examples of
Gaussian of contours of Gaussian
densities with zero off diagonal so the
axis here and thanks more than x2 right
whereas you cannot model something like
this if you're 0 if you're off diagonals
are 0 and so if you do this the maximum
likely estimate of the parameters Sigma
J is pretty much what you'd expect
actually the maximum like give you an
estimate of the mean vector mu is the
same as before and this is Mathematica
estimate of Sigma J right this is kind
of not a huge surprise gonna put you
things back oh and it turns out that and
so the covariance matrix here as n
parameters instead of in spirit or about
n square over 2 parameters the
covariance matrix Sigma now just as in
parameters which the n diagonal entries
now the problem with this is that this
molding assumption assumes that all of
your features are uncorrelated right so
you know this just assumes that any two
features they connect share are
completely uncorrelated and
if you have temperature sensors in this
room there's just not a good assumption
to assume the temperature at all points
of this room are completely uncorrelated
completely independent
each other or if you measure yes the
glaciers the people is just not a great
assumption to assume that you know the
different different psychological
measures you might have a completely
independent so while this model would
take care of the problem the the
technical problem of the covariance
matrix being singular you can't fit this
model on a hundred dimensional data set
with 30 examples you can fit this you
won't get in you this you could build
this model you won't run into numerical
or singular cover and species size
problems it's just not a very good model
you're just assuming nothing is
correlated than anything else
something else that you can do is make
an even stronger assumption so this is
an even worse model but I go through it
because there'll be a building buffer
will actually do later which is
constraint Sigma to be Sigma equals
lowercase Sigma squared times R right
and so constraint Sigma to be done not
only diagonal but to have the same entry
in every single element so now you've
gone from I guess n parameters to just
one parameter right and this means that
you're constraining the covariance
matrix the constraining the gaussians
you used to have circular control so
this is an example of what you can model
and this would be another example this
is another example okay so you could
model things like this where every
feature not only is every features
uncorrelated but every feature further
has the same variance as every other
feature and maximum likelihood is this
not a huge surprise does the average
over the previous values so what we'd
like to do is not quite used either of
these options right which assumes really
bigger problems as soon as the features
are uncorrelated and what we'd like to
do is build a model that you can fit
even when you have very high dimensional
data and the relatively small number of
examples but that allows you to capture
some of the correlations right so if we
have 30 temperature sensors in this room
you know probably there are some
correlations very probably decided in
the room temperature is gonna be
correlated data of insertion correlated
and maybe the ambient temperature in
this whole building or the temperature
of this room pretty girls up and down
there's a whole but maybe some of the
lands on the side heat up that's out of
the room a bit more so different
different there are correlations but
maybe you don't need for
covariance matrix either so what what
factor analysis we'll do is give us a
model that you can fit even when you
have you know hundred emissions a there
are thirty examples they captures some
of the correlations but that doesn't run
into the onion vertical covariance
matrices that the naive Gaussian model
does alright so let me just just track
anyone let me let me describe the models
check any questions by anyone oh sure
yes yes there is one thing you can do a
common thing to do is apply which hot
Pryor and what that boils down to is as
a small diagonal value to that to the
maximum I could estimate it kind of in a
technical sense it takes away the
non-invertible matrix problem there's
actually not the best algorithm from
other types of danger the the the
Wishart or inverse Wishart prior yeah as
you know basically you take the maximum
likely the Sigma and add you know some
constant to the diagonal it take has the
problem in a technical way but it's not
it's not the best model for a lot of
data says I see
oh yes why do you think about option two
when it's like even worse than option
one um yes option two is not a good
option but I need to use this as a
building block for factor analysis so
you see this is a small component of C I
actually plan these things out and I
actually took on it's just just a
mention you know just mentioned some
things I see yeah she's actually did the
machine there any work he balls all the
time we should find it fascinating but
they look at all the big tech companies
um a lot of the large tech companies
they're all like working on exactly the
same problems right every large tech
company you know software AI complete
his work on machine translation every
one of them works on speech recognition
every one of them works on face
recognition and I've been part of these
teams myself right and I think it's
great that we have so much progress in
machine translation cuz there's so many
people in so many large companies work
on machine translation it's actually
really happy to see so much progress in
these problems that every single large
tech company large software a Irish tech
company works on um one of the
fascinating things I see is that because
of all this work in the large tech
companies work on very similar problems
one of the really overlooked parts of
the machine there any world is a small
data problems right so they're all
working big data representing English
and French and Chinese and Spanish
sentences it's in across small does it
work and I think there's actually a lack
of attention like a disproportionate
small amount of attention on you know
small data problems we're instead of a
hundred million images you maybe have
100 images and so some of the teams I
work with these days actually landing a
I actually spent all my time thinking
about small danger problems because a
lot of the practical applications of
machine learning including the wrong
things you see in your class projects or
actually small data problems right I
think when when onion works with the
healthcare system where our substantive
Hospital force all the problems you only
have 100 examples only a thousand only
10,000 you don't have a million patients
or the same medical condition and so I
think that a lot of these models so in
the game earlier this week I was using
slightly modified version
factor analysis on the manufacturing
problem at landing AI right and I think
a lot of these small data problems are
actually we're allowed the exciting work
is to be done in machine learning and is
somehow it feels like a blind spot or
the feels like girls like a a good gap
of a lot of their work done into a I
world today yeah why don't we use the
same arrow as a swan big data it turns
out that you know it turns out if you
look at computer vision world right is a
dataset everyone's working on now now
we're pasta we don't really use anymore
called image net which had a million
images and so the tons of computation
architectures that have been heavily
designed for the use case of if you have
exactly 1 million training examples it
turns out that the algorithms that work
best maybe have 100 training examples is
you know looks like is different than
the best learning algorithm I think and
so I think right now we actually I think
the Machine there any world we are not
very good at understanding the scaling
the best algorithm for one training
example you know as far as we are able
to invent algorithm mister community is
different than best algorithm for a
thousand best earn per million is
actually different than actually and
Facebook published paper we see with 3.5
billion images there's no school there's
very large right so was I think we don't
actually have a good understanding of
how to modify our algorithms set one
algorithm work on every single point of
the spectrum green from one example to
like a billion examples and so there's a
lot of work optimizing for different
points of the spectrum and I think
there's been a lot of work optimizing
for Big Data which is great you know
built some of these large systems to
handle whatever I petabytes of data a
day that's great
but I feel like relative to the number
of application opportunities there there
there's a lot of work on small data as
well that I find very exciting that
that and I think of this as an example
the reason I was using this literally
well modified version of this earlier
this week on the manufacturing problem
is because there isn't that much data in
those scenarios right all right those
them off topic but let's go and describe
well hopefully maybe yeah so this stuff
does get used right so let's let's talk
about the model so similar to your
information of Gaussian is I'm going to
define a model with PXE equals to P of X
given Z times P of Z and Z is hidden ok
so that's a framework same as mixture of
gaussians so let me just define the
factor analysis model
so first um Z will be drawn distributed
according to a Gaussian density where Z
is going to be an R D where D is less
than n and again to think about it maybe
in think of it as on D equals 3 N equals
100 M equals 30 okay and and but I guess
just did me just as a concrete example
to think about it and what we're going
to assume is that X is equal to mu plus
lambda Z this is the capital Greek
alphabet lambda plus epsilon where
epsilon is disputed Gaussian with mean 0
and covariance psy
so the parameters of this model are mu
which is n dimensional lambda which is n
by D and psy which is n by n and we're
going to assume that psy is diagonal
okay and so let's see the second
equation an equivalent way to write that
is that given the value of Z the
conditional distribution of X right X
given Z this is Gaussian with me given
by mu plus lambda Z and kobir inside
okay so once you've given Z once your
sample Z so this is P of Z and this is P
P of Z and SP of XE X given Z right so
given Z X is computed as mu plus lambda
Z so this is just some constant and then
you add Gaussian noise to it and so this
equation an equivalent way to defining
this equation is to say that the mean of
X conditioned on Z is this first term
since that's the mean and the covariance
of x given Z is given by this you know
additional term for sy by that noise
term that you had to it okay
so let me go through a few examples and
I think the intuition behind this model
is in if you think that there are three
powerful forces driving temperatures
across this room maybe one powerful
force is just what is the temperature
you know here in Palo Alto what's the
temperature here at Stanford and another
powerful force is how bright are the
lights on the left side of the room and
how hot does it heat up the side of room
and another is how hot does it heat up
the right side of the group right so
let's say there are three main driving
factors affecting the temperature of
this room then that's when D would be
equal to three that you assume that you
know there are three things in the world
they drive the temperature of this room
this three dimensional which is the
temperature in Palo Alto kind of around
this area how bright are the lies there
and how bright otherwise they're and you
try to capture that with three numbers
given those three numbers right given Z
the actual temperature for the 100
sensors we scatter around this room will
be determined by each sensor right so
plant 30 temperature sensors all over
this room each sensor we plant will
measure an actual temperature there's a
linear function of those three powerful
forces and if it sends it on that side
of the room it will be affected more by
how bright are the lights on that side
of the room if the sensor near the door
it will be more affected by the
temperature outside temperature here in
Palo Alto right but so X will be a
linear function this first time I
underlined but rather than just that
term there's a little noise right so
your sensor has his own noise term which
is governed by this additional noise
term epsilon and the assumption that
this matrix psy is diagonal is saying
that after you compute the mean the
noise that you observe that your sensor
is independent of the noise and every
other sensor right there maybe maybe the
sensor you know up there right maybe
it's just noisy or something this gust
of wind but you assume that the noise
observe at different senses is
independent
the additional epsilon error term has a
diagonal covariance matrix given by side
okay so you can so you can think of that
as what factor analysis is trying to
model so let me um you just go through a
couple of examples of the types of data
factor analysis can model alright oh and
again body constrains the white board
I'm gonna have to go low-dimensional
here so actually let me let me go
through a couple examples so let's say Z
is R 1 and x is r 2 so in this example I
guess D is equal to 1 and is equal to 2
and let's say M is 7 right just just so
won't be a typical sample generated by
you know what would be an example of a
type of data that disc can model so this
so this would be a typical sample of Zi
which is you know so this is Z is just
drawn from a static alcian so I guess Z
miss Gaussian with mean 0 unit variance
so that's a number line and if you draw
seven points from the Gaussian you know
maybe you get a sample like that okay
and now let's say lambda is two one and
let's just say mu is zero zero okay so
now let's compute lambda X plus mu so
give it a sample like that
if you computes lambda X plus mu this
will now be an r2 right so here's X 1 is
X 2 I'm gonna take those examples and
map them to align as follows right wait
these examples on R 1 so oh excuse me
long disease okay so this is just a real
number and so lambda Z plus mu is now
two-dimensional right because uh lambda
R it's a 2 by 1 matrix okay so you end
up with so this would be a typical
sample to look around the sample of
lambda Z plus mu and there's a 2
dimensional data set but all of the
examples lie perfectly on a straight
line okay
then finally let's say that sy the
covariance matrix is equal to this as a
diagonal covariance matrix and so this
covariance matrix corresponds to x2
having a bigger Berens the next one
right now so you know this this I guess
the density of epsilon has ellipses that
look a little bit like this is taller
than Y the aspect ratio should
technically be 1 over root 2
right there's a standard deviation would
be root 2 oh yes and so in the last step
of what we're going to do x equals
lambda Z plus mu those Epsilon we're
going to take each of these points we
have and put a little Gaussian contour
you know there's that shape there's this
this I'm just doing one contour yes it
is a shape and just puts it on top of
this and if you sample one point from
each of these gaussians there may be
again this example this example this
example this example so what I just did
was looking into the Gaussian contours
in sample a point from that Gaussian and
so the red crosses here are a typical
sample drawn from this model okay and so
if you have data that looks like this
that looks like the red crosses come
disease are latent random variables
right and when you get it is that you
can't actually see Z so what you
actually see is just you know the red
crosses that's your training set and if
you apply the factor analysis model with
these parameters then you know by e/m
and so on hopefully you can find
parameters and all those this data set
pretty well but hopefully this to the
sense of the type of data set this could
generate
and so and so um and then one one way to
think of this data is you have two
dimensional data but most of the data
lies on a 1d subspace so this is how to
think about it you have two dimensional
data since n is two but most of the data
lies on the roughly one dimensional
subspace meaning lies are up there on
the line and then there's a little bit
of noise off that line okay all right
let me quickly do one more example
because these are these are high
dimensional spaces I think this I think
is useful to build intuition all right
um
so let's go through the example where Z
is 2 X is an r3 and let's use M equals
5/2 so um what about different set of
parameters let's look at the type of
data you can generate a factor analysis
which is just e 1 is e 2 Z is
distributed Gaussian standing goes in to
do you so beyond you know circular
Gaussian so maybe this is what a typical
sample right looks like if you if you
sample sort of z1 and z2 from a standard
Gaussian right that would be a typical
sample in z1 and z2 so now all right I'm
gonna do a demo let me take these five
examples and just copy them to this
piece of paper okay so all right there
great transfer this from the whiteboard
to this piece of paper to this brown
cardboard so now you have z1 and z2 in a
two dimensional space what we're going
to do is compute lambda Z plus mu and
this will be 3 by 2 and this will be 3
by 1
so what this computation will do as you
map from Z in two dimensions to lambda Z
plus mu is you're going to map from
two-dimensional data to
three-dimensional data in other words
you're going to take the two dimensional
data lying on the plane of the
whiteboard and map it check out the
school animation into the
three-dimensional space of our classroom
and then the last step is for each of
these points in this video space like X
1 X 2 X 3 right we'll have a little
Gaussian bump that is acts as a line
because epsilon is the features the the
components of epsilon are uncorrelated
and taking each of these five points and
add the low you know be the fuzziness a
little bit of Gaussian noise to it and
so what you end up with is a set of red
crosses and you end up with a few
examples you know L above the noise you
end up with except that they would have
a bit of noise off this plane as well
right but so what the factor analysis
model can capture is if you have data in
3d right in this 3d space but most of
the data set lies on this maybe roughly
two dimensional pancake but there's a
little bit of fuzziness off the
packaging right so so this would be an
example of the type of data that factor
analysis can model
and the intuition is really think factor
analysis can take very high-dimensional
data say 100 dimensional data and model
the data is roughly lying on a three
dimensional five dimensional subspace
with a little bit of fuss will blow of
noise of that low dimensional subspace
so let's talk about Oh right does not
work as well if the data is not lying on
the load original subspace um let's see
so even in 2d if you have this data set
your I should the freedom to choose
Gaussian noise just like that in which
case you can actually model things that
quite far off a subspace but yeah you
know I think we're very high dimensional
dataset it's actually very difficult to
know what's going on because you can't
visualize these very high dimensional
data sets and you also don't have enough
data to go very secure to models so so I
feel like yes if you have if the data
actually does not roughly line the
subspace then this model you know may
not be the best model but when you have
such high dimensional data in such a
small data set
you can't fit very complex models to it
anyway so this might be pretty
reasonable so um so it turns out that
the derivation of vm for factor analysis
is actually is actually one of the
trickiest VM derivations in terms of how
you calculate at each step and how you
calculate the m-step the whole algorithm
is you know describe every every every
single step step through in great detail
the lecture notes but what I want to do
is give you the flavor of how to do the
derivation and to especially draw
attention to the trickiest step so that
if you need to derive an algorithm like
this yourself or maybe a different
Gaussian model that you know how to do
it but I won't do every step the algebra
here um so in order to set ourselves up
to derive factor analysis here enm for
better analysis I want to describe a few
properties of multivariate gaussians
so let's say that X is a vector and I'm
gonna write this as a partition vector
right and we jumped if there are our
components there and s components there
so x1 is in SS so if X is Gaussian with
mean mu and covariance Sigma then let's
similarly let me be written as this sort
of partition vector right just break it
up into two sub vectors corresponding to
the first R components in the second s
components and similarly lesson that the
covariance matrix be partitioned into
you know these four diagonal blocks
where I guess this is our components
this is s components this is our
components this is s components so all
this means is you take the covariance
matrix and take the top leftmost R by R
elements and call that Sigma 1 1 right
and and similarly for the other sub
blocks of this covariance matrix so in
order to derive factor analysis one of
the things you need to do is compute
marginal and conditional distributions
of gaussians so the marginal is you know
what is P of x1 and so the the if you
you know where to derive this the way
you compute the marginal is to take the
joint density of P of X right and you
can write this as P of x1 x2 because X
can be partitioned into x1 and x2 and
then integrate out x2
P of X 1 X 2 right DX 2 and just to give
you P of X 1 and if you plug in the
Gaussian density the formula for the
Gaussian density if you plug in I guess
you know 1 over 2 pi to the N over 2 C
it was in one half e to the minus 1/2 X
1 minus mu 1 if you plug this into P of
X 1 comma X 2 and as she do the integral
then you will find that the marginal
distribution of X 1 is given by X 1 is a
Gaussian with mean mu 1 and covariance
Sigma 1 1 so it's kind of not a shocking
result that the marginal distribution is
given just by that and that's and then
again the way to show it vigorously is
to do this calculation but it's actually
not shocking I guess that that's what
you would get ok um and then the other
property you will need to use is a
conditional which is given the value of
X 2 what is the conditional value of x 1
and so the way to do that would be you
know in theory you would take P of X 1
comma X 2 divided by P of X 2 right and
then simplify and it turns out you can
show that X 1 given X 2 is itself
Gaussian or some mean in some covariance
which comes right at some U of 1 given 2
and Sigma of 1 given 2 over mu of 1
given 2 is and but this is one of those
long is that I actually don't
I actually don't manage to remember but
every time I need
just look what is written election I was
as well so so that's how you compute
modules and conditionals of a Gaussian
distribution
so using these properties of the
multivariate Gaussian density let's go
through the high-level steps of how you
derive the EML rule
step one is less compute actually let's
let's derive what is the joint
distribution of P of X and Z and in
particular it turns out that if you take
Z and X and stack them up into a vector
like so Z and X viewed as a vector will
be Gaussian wouldn't mean with some mean
and some Co various because X and Z
jointly will have a Gaussian density and
let's try to quickly figure out what are
this mean and that's covariance matrix
so that was a definition of these terms
and so the expected value of Z is equal
to 0 because 0 Z is Gaussian with mean 0
and covariance identity and do you
expected value of x is equal to the
expected value of mu plus lambda Z plus
epsilon but Z has 0 expected value
epsilon 0 expected value so that just
leaves you with mu and so this mean
vector mu XZ is going to equal to 0 and
so this is d dimensional and this is a n
dimensional and it turns out that let's
see
and it turns out that you can similarly
compute the covariance matrix Sigma
right where this is D dimensions and
this is n dimensions it turns out that
if you take this partition vector and
compute the covariance matrix the four
blocks of the covariance matrix that can
be written as follows and you can
one-at-a-time derive what each of these
different blocks look like and let me
just do one of these and now let me just
derive one Sigma 2 to the lower-right
blockers and the rest are derived
similarly and also fleshed out in the
lecture notes
so the way you derive what this block is
like is that you say Sigma 2 2 is X
minus y X X minus X transpose and so if
I plug in the definition of X that would
be a lambda Z plus mu plus epsilon minus
mu the same thing so that's X minus yeah
so that's X minus y X okay because the
expected value of x is 2 so the Meuse
cancel out and then if you do the
quadratic expansion I guess this becomes
expected value of let's see
lambda Z times each of these two terms
transpose plus it's all about you know a
plus B times a plus B right is a times a
times a plus B times a plus B you get
four terms as a result and so the first
term is lambda Z times lambda Z
transpose which is this plus lambda Z
epsilon transpose plus with Epsilon
and so this term has your expected value
because epsilon and and Z both have zero
expected value and correlated so this is
0 this is 0 on expectation and so you
just left with an expected value of
lambda Z Z transpose lambda transpose
plus the expected value of epsilon
epsilon transpose and so by the
linearity of expectation you can take a
expectation inside the mouth matrix
multiplication so this launder is the
expected value of Z Z transpose times
lambda transpose plus and this is just
the covariance of epsilon right which is
which is Sai and then because Z is drawn
from a standard Gaussian with identity
covariance that expectation in the
middle is just the identity
so there's lambda lambda transpose plus
sign okay so that's how you work out
what is this lower right block of this
um covariance matrix I know I did that a
little bit quickly but every every step
is written out more slowly into lecture
notes as well and it turns out that if
you go through a similar process at
Phaedra you know one at a time using a
similar process what are the other
blocks of this covariance matrix you
find that the other blocks of this
covariance matrix are identity lounder
transpose that one we just worked out so
that that's the one we just worked out
but so that is the covariance matrix
side
so where we are is that we figured out
that the joint distribution at the joint
density of Z X is Gaussian would mean
given by that vector and covariance
given by that matrix and so what you
could do is you write down write P of X
I and try to take the so P of X I will
be this Gaussian density and what you
could do is take derivatives of the
log-likelihood respect to the parameters
instead on 0 0 and solve and you find
that there is no known closed form
solution there is actually no closed
form solution for finding the values of
lambda and sy and mu that maximizes life
likelihood so in order to fit the
parameters of the model we're instead
going to resort to Y M and so in the
estep
so let's let's first derive what is the
e step which is an e step you need to
compute this now Zi here is a continuous
random variable when we're fitting a
mixture of gaussians distribution Zi was
discrete and so you could have a list of
numbers represented by you know W IJ
that just just have a vector soaring
what is the probability of each of the
discrete values of Zi but in this case
Zi is a continuous density so how do you
represent qi of Zi in a computer it
turns out that using the formulas we
have for the marginal excuse me for the
conditional distribution of a Gaussian
it turns out that if you compute this
right hand side you'll find that Zi
given X I this is going to be Gaussian
with some mean and some covariance right
where it's basically those formulas mu
of Z i given X I is equal to if you kind
of take that foam and then apply it all
thing here is 0 plus lambda transpose
okay so these equations are exactly
these two equations right maps to map to
that big Gaussian density that we have
okay so what you would do in the East
step is compute this and compute this
compute this vector in computers matrix
and saw that sorters in you know store
these as variables and your
representation of the Qi is that Qi is a
Gaussian density right with this mean
and disco beer so this is what you
actually compute to represent Qi
all right so step two was to write the e
step and step three is the RIVM step and
the derivation of the m-step is is quite
long and complicated but I want to
mention just a key out your algebraic
trick you need to use when deriving the
m-step so you know we know from the east
step that qi of zi is that gaussian
density right so yes 1 over 2 pi to the
D over 2 that thing and e to the
negative 1/2 so that's the formula for
Qi it turns out that in the m-step
there'll be a few places in the
derivation where you need to compute
something like this and one way to
approach this would be to plug in the
density for Qi which is so you end up
with this 1/2 pi to the T over 2 Sigma
you know and so on time zi Dzi and then
charlie compute this integral it turns
out there's a much simpler way to
computers in the draw anyone know what
it is
all right cool awesome right expect the
value so the other way to compute this
integral is to note that is that this is
the expected value of CI when CI is
drawn from Qi right so you know the
definition of expect about value of
random variables
expected value of Z is equal to integral
over C probably up to Z times Z DZ right
that's what the expected value of a
random variable is and so this integral
is the expected value of Z respect to Z
drawn from the QI distribution but we
know that Q is Gaussian with a certain
mean a certain variance and so the
expected value of this this is just mu
of Z i given X I is that thing that
you've already computed and so when
students derived the m-step you know for
young implementations of gaussians one
of the key things to notice is when are
you actually taking an expected value
respect to around in variable in which
case is just the value of computer
already and when do you need to plug in
this big complicated integral which can
lead to very complicated very
intractable calculations ok so just when
you're whenever you see this think about
whether you need to be expanding a big
complicated integral or if it can be
interpreted as an expected out
and so for the m-step is really you know
the m-step
is right so that's the m-step
and if you rewrite this term as on some
of I the expected value of Zi drawn from
Qi it turns out that um if you go ahead
and plug in the Gaussian density here
actually want one rule of thumb for
whether or not you should plug in a
complicated in the grow-op sarcoma
Gaussian density this is just a rule of
thumb after doing this type of map a
long time it see if there's a log in
front if there's a log in front of a
Gaussian density because the Gaussian
density as an exponentiation right
through the Gaussian density is you know
1 over e to the something so one of
there's a log in front of volcanic
initiation cancel out and this equations
simplify so one trick as you're doing
these derivations is just see if there's
a log in front of a Gaussian density and
when there is a plugin go ahead and plug
in the formulas for Gaussian density the
log will simplify that and what you end
up with is the log of a Gaussian density
as there being a quadratic function
a quadratic function of the parameters
and if you take the expected value
respect to a Gaussian Jessie respect to
a quadratic function this whole thing
ends up being a quadratic function and
then you can take derivatives of that
equation with respect to the parameters
respective new that whole thing set it
to zero and then solve and it'll be
roughly
love of complexity of maximizing
quadratic function okay hope that makes
sense um the actual formulas are a
little bit complicated so I don't I'll
leave user luckily I shall for this the
lecture notes but I think the takeaway
is uh don't expand this in the draw and
when you are deriving this plug in the
Gaussian densities here because they'll
all be simplified okay and details of
it's an election notes so let's break
for today best of luck with the midterm
oh and no Suzy I hope you guys do well
alright I'll see you guys in a few days